in this video i'm going to show you the
best rendering settings to use in after
effects for all the different projects
[Music]
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science and i've been working with after
effects for over 20 years now and in
that time render settings have come and
gone and they've changed quite a bit
but in today's video i want to show you
the render settings the containers the
codecs that you should be using on your
projects right now okay here we are
inside of after effects and when
rendering out of after effects we have
two ways of doing that one way is to use
the render queue which we see here and
the second way is to use the media
encoder application that we'll take a
look at in just a second now if you
don't know how to set up a render you're
going to go to your composition you're
going to go up to composition add to
render queue and when you do that it
adds the composition to the render queue
down here
and
there's a couple different settings
there's there's render settings which we
see here set to best there's output too
which is where we're going to tell after
effects to render to and what it's going
to be called and then there's output
module now yours probably doesn't say
prores 422hq that doesn't matter because
all you need to do is click on it and
you can launch the output module
settings so when we talk about rendering
we have to talk about codecs and
containers the codec is the actual
software that does the compressing
of your video file while the container
is the package the final project is
delivered in for playback and the most
common containers are mov and mp4 files
now once you pick a container like a
quicktime you have format options here
and these are known as codecs codecs are
a method for encoding and decoding video
data or in other words it's the way that
the video data
the audio data the graphics are encoded
or
compressed the more compressed a file
the smaller the file size is going to be
you can also lose image quality in
compression the least compressed
file is going to be a larger file size
and look better as well so looking at
the codex for our quicktime we have
animation which is going to look really
awesome but it's going to have be a
really large file size and then we have
apple prores which is an industry
standard for delivering
a
final delivery of your
motion design piece to a client
typically i'm going to use apple prores
422 hq
but you can use 422.
lt is more of a format for getting a
client approval
same with proxy apple prores 444 is a
super high res file that includes
information for an alpha channel so we
have uh that last four here is actually
representative of our alpha channel
there's also a lot of other codecs
listed here there may be additional ones
that you have if you're on a windows
machine now if i leave this on prores
422hq
and i click
ok
you can see that i am not able to add
color plus alpha and if you don't
understand what alpha is it's basically
the transparency of a file so if i want
to include alpha i need to go back into
my format options click on four four
four four
click ok
and i can go back and now i am able to
select rgb plus alpha i also have my
audio settings here i typically leave it
on auto but you can put output on or
output off and adjust settings here as
well now if you want to render to any
type of format for client approval or
you're going to the web i'm going to
recommend that you use the media encoder
how we do that is we go back to our
composition window
composition add to adobe media encoder
queue
it's going to launch media encoder and
here we are inside a media encoder and
you can see it gives you an output and a
preset so basically this is the
container and this is the codec so if i
want to use quicktime i can do that here
or i can go down to something like h.264
which is going to give me a pretty good
compression and i can pick from presets
now i have pre-built presets up here
that i've created for myself
under those we have a lot of different
presets that we can use i personally
like to use high quality 1080p
as a preset it's a really awesome preset
to use for things like youtube i also
use it for client approvals and things
like that now if i want to go in i can
actually click on that preset and i can
go in and start changing
parameters about that preset adjusting
the codec so this composition has no
audio in it so i'm going to immediately
turn off the audio
i'm going to scroll down under video
settings here i'm going to render at
maximum depth keep on scrolling down you
can adjust these settings if you want to
typically i don't
vbr one pass or vbr 2 pass or constant
bitrate it's totally up to you
this is what the target bit rate is for
the preset i chose which is 20 and a
maximum bit rate of 24. again you can
play around these settings if you're
sending a file off to a client
and it doesn't have to be super high res
i would crank these values way down
typically when you're sending a file to
a client you want to keep that file as
small as possible now going down here i
can see the estimated file size is 10
megabytes and that's pretty good for a
client review that's actually really
good but if for some reason i need to
turn that down all i need to do is just
crank this value down here you can see
now we're down to an estimated file size
of 4 megabytes i may turn this one down
as well and i can click ok and we're
ready to render i can also go ahead and
select that output command d to
duplicate it and i can change my
container here to something like a
quicktime
and you can see there's a lot of
different
presets in here as well and i can pick a
preset that i've created i can also do
the same thing where i click and come in
and
put in some different settings here it's
completely up to you media encoder is
very very deep but the main thing i want
to get across here is when you are
rendering for client previews
or you're going to social media channels
you want to typically work with h.264
which you can see here or
h265hevc which is actually a smaller
file format but can take a little bit
longer to encode those are two great
ones for that if you are rendering for
client purposes and you need to have a
high-res file i'm going to recommend
that you stick with apple prores 422hq
or one of these variations of it or
apple prores
4444 a variation of that as well i hope
that you really enjoyed this lesson as
much as i loved teaching it so please
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments below i'd love to answer
them for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro i have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]
you